[Music]
Hey oh my god
one time I was watching planet Earth do
you ever watch that show
yeah what is strange why I'm so excited
to be sitting here with my new friend
Eliza coupe you may recognize her from
scrubs happy endings just being real
yeah what's your tattoo though oh
there's so many do you have a lot of
tattoos they do you don't have taught to
face well I don't mean to have two faces
a bad face no in fact I actually really
like roles that have tattoos I just
really face your faces and cool pies
yeah can you tell me about something sad
mm yes lift through your daughter cuz
I'm from New Hampshire the ham shock
yeah well pop from Plymouth living all
town way up north white mountain areas a
little Plymouth Plantation is Plymouth
Plantation is is a thing where you
pretended it was the past yeah oh my god
I love to go in there right like that
once I went there once I make it I just
made it sound like I went there all the
time they did my mother like yeah we're
gonna change the name in the segment
from Gavin to lion with Eliza lot with
Eliza I like this fella do you know it's
a witch's peel Oh
exactly wearing it yeah I thought
Muppets like a muppet pube touch boobs
how are you sleeping lately I go to bed
very early what times early anywhere
between seven and you know eleven eight
I love me what time are we getting that
anywhere between 3:30 and 4:00
voluntarily okay you've lost me yeah I
know there's a lot of people there
that's why I five - friends - well you
have a boyfriend
thank you what do you think about you
getting up at the hour that most people
are getting up to murder people the Sun
can't beat me to getting up I get up
before the Sun I say when it's morning
when the Sun shows up good
where are you yeah yeah and you're
already glazing yes that's what they say
just giving vitamin D to humans yes
you were raised kind of like a boy even
though you're a lady
what does that mean Oh
dick did he owe less than um yeah I was
I was raised I played ice hockey ice
hockey whoa
most of you I did have to change in the
locker room with them did you really
change in the dressing dressing not a
sports person I had so backstage
we got our props that stick and in the
first act how many points was scripted
ABC Gorge
these are constellations I was gonna say
that yeah these socks are finally
answering the critics that are like
could Cassiopeia sweat mmm
[Laughter]
labia sound clumsy very knows what's
going on I got glasses really late in
life and didn't know that you were
supposed to be able to see like
individual leaves on trees I was like
that's supposed to just look like a blob
right really whoa I never I lived in New
York and then I never had to drive until
I came out here and I was driving out
here and I'd be driving and like you
know when you squint at a Christmas tree
QQ in a ravine the 101 is real bumpy
today soon guys no no I'm allergic to
him so I can see you yeah let's play
kill marry but only with Meryl Streep
try to be female
Meryl Streep's okay okay god I gotta go
Meryl Streep Prem is complicated
The Devil Wears Prada Meryl or Julia
Julia and Julia
well here's the thing immediately I want
to kill Julia Julia Julia but she would
make wonderful food yeah wonderful food
you would never starve right um but it
would be like bone marrow yeah and I
don't like mankind a food
why'd it take me all this time to
realize that Julia Child was Miss Piggy
how do you feel about a hood probably
open mouth guess is better I open my
eyes first got weird let's do it
let's see you hi
[Applause]
[Music]